la NASA qui faisait à peu près tout dans
les années 80-90 est passé à une logique
de non plus faire mais faire faire alors
elle continue à faire des choses avec
une expertise technique très forte mais
elle a davantage
favoriser l'émergence secteur privé qui
aujourd'hui sont à la pointe de
l'innovation de l'audace de la prise de
risque avec des investissements privés
et donc on connaît le résultat avec un
Space X qui aujourd'hui enfin je crois
qu'il a prévu pour 2023 200 lancements
donc c'est
ou 2024 peut-être
donc c'est un lancement par semaine
depuis maintenant presque un an là où
l'Europe fait a fait cette année cinq
lancements pour des raisons que on
connaît mais donc oui alors tout n'est
pas perdu néanmoins
on a écrit dans notre tribune que on
était en situation de disparition
gravitaire bon c'est un terme de
technoning des plaques à un moment donné
vous avez un trou qui s'ouvre et poumons
disparaît alors qu'on était là un moment
donné
mais mais encore une fois on a des
atouts très forts on a une volonté
politique on a un dispositif en 2030 il
y a un milliard et demi d'euros
subventions pour de l'espace pour
l'espace dont un milliard pour des
acteurs émergents donc tout ça et tout
ça est très bien et il y a des gens qui
ont envie de faire des choses maintenant
il y a encore des choses à améliorer je
pense que sur la question de
l'organisation de la gouvernance en
France
je pense qu'on pourrait faire mieux il y
a aussi la question du rôle en Europe de
la place de la France dans l'Europe et
donc de l'Europe est-ce que la France la
France doit rester une nation spatiale
mais à mon avis elle ne peut plus porter
seul des projets enfin ne peut pas
apporter seul des projets comme une
station spatiale internationale etc ça
c'est fini des pays comme les émirs
arabes unis peuvent le faire parce
qu'ils ont des ressources financières
très importantes mais ils le font
d'ailleurs
mais la France non donc la France c'est
la question c'est la place c'est
l'ambition européenne et la place de la
France dans cette ambition européenne à
mon sens
et si on arrive à résoudre cette
question qui passe aussi par à mon avis
une réflexion sur la un peu la
gouvernance et l'organisation au niveau
européen c'est-à-dire l'articulation
entre les agences nationales et donc les
États membres d'une part la Commission
européenne autre part et l'Agence
spatiale européenne les a d'autre part
question qui n'est pas réglée qui qui
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ça existe ça fonctionne mais
mais c'est quand même ça reste une
question difficile
[Musique]
je pense que si on arrive à avancer sur
ces sujets là l'Europe peut avoir une
vraie ambition spatiale et revenir au
meilleur niveau et la France joue un
rôle particulier